hey everybody it's me and I'm back from
the dead this is unbelievable my tour
solo is on pause because the Impractical
Jokers national tour has started the
arena tour tickets are on sale for the
first leg of it right now at impractical
jokerslive.com we're coming to Reading
Pennsylvania we're coming to uh Stony
Brook we're coming to Pittsburgh Camden
New Jersey Boston we're coming to
Charleston South Carolina Charlotte
North Carolina Waterloo New York uh
Washington DC Niagara Falls Newark
Wallingford Belmont Park we're playing
that UBS Arena and the Prudential arena
in Jersey Milwaukee Rosemont Seattle
Portland I mean guys Utah Denver
Arlington Austin Sugar Land Columbus
Cleveland Detroit Minneapolis Des Moines
Kansas City I'm getting tired Nashville
Indianapolis and St Louis that's just
what's announced right now and it's all
on sale right now we're revving up right
now the show's gonna be a blast we
haven't been out in years hope to see
you there in practicejokerslive.com
what's up baby a brand new hour of
stand-up material go to chrisdcomedy.com
for Ticky Wiki's January 12th in New
Orleans January 13th in Dallas is sold
out January 14th in Houston is almost
sold out or might be sold out and then
January 26th to the 28th Phoenix Arizona
brand new hour of stand up come check it
[Music]
out
like a good neighbor hey baby's there
hey baby hey what insurance do you have
uh for what for car for car let's start
I want to go one insurance you have a
car what insurance do you have for
health what insurance do you have for
home and what insurance do you have for
life okay
I used to have bikes for many years well
you're a Geico I had but you're a big
guy I think I'm a big guy huge
huge guy huge guy yeah yeah yeah that
should be their commercials
be a bull guy yeah
um uh I mean I want to say [ __ ] 15
yeah hey I'll build your house I'm a
carpenter I do it with bulldog
hey look at me I'm Jade Lynch
the spokesman is a little bull gike
uh
I switched over to uh I got umbrella
like I got I went to it we got umbrella
coverage yeah I went to like a insurance
agent and then they did everything got
it okay I think I'm like I think it's
pretty aggressive so what I got is I
don't know I should know this for life
insurance I got William Penn like
William Penn was a good guy William Penn
named there for the Pennsylvania can I
see it no it's William Tell okay good uh
what song are you gonna sing and I feel
like well yeah pulling muscles from a
shell
throwing muscles yeah what do you mean
but it looks good kill there's a man
but I have my feel pulling muscles from
it's famous you know what what's the
name of the band pull it pulling muscles
from a shell pull okay pulling hey babe
I like anytime somebody doesn't know the
words to a song you always go deaf like
it would sound like you're deaf like
you'd be like
never once in my life have you heard
this pill you need it never I don't I'm
not honestly if young gravy doesn't
cover it I don't know it he will he over
that he wouldn't
he would do something like that sure I
by the way shout out young gravy love
you I love this boy young gravy we
opened up the saw on last week's episode
Cheryl with Cheryl which is the funniest
name for I think that the name of that
song made me laugh hysterically yeah
name that song Cheryl first of all so I
I will be I I slept on young graveyard I
was the one who told you about younger I
I didn't know who he was I know what
happened I was in town doing a show
um somewhere uh Sarasota Florida no uh
um Chicago possibly okay I was recently
one more guess Dayton Ohio no okay uh so
anyway I was doing and I was like oh man
like we we it was we it was hard to sell
tickets and I found well I told you I
told you I said that night Billy Joel
was there Adam Sandler was there oh yeah
the B-52 is with him it was Atlanta I
remember because he had the two shows
there was a free concert in the park and
then young gravy was there and I was
like I know everybody I don't think I
know you on gravy so I looked up young
gravy Atlanta also headquarters Allstate
oh right yeah Allstate Arena that's
where they play so it's just just an
option if in the umbrella coverage you
think about also okay I will I will
think about that because everything's on
the table so yeah uh I looked up and I
googled young gravy and then I listened
to a couple I was cracking up and I
texted you I'm like there's a dude named
young gravy that's playing here and his
I said one of the lyrics in the first
song I listened to was I went to the
store for some chocolate flavored milk
came home with a thick chocolate covered
MILF yes and you said young gravy was
supposed to be on all podcast possibly
yes young gravy we felt that just
because of what you know what was
leading up to we're like Sal's gonna die
for about eight weeks yeah yeah so we
knew we were gonna drop dead for eight
weeks and in that time we were you know
you were like oh let's see if we can get
comparable co-host someone even in the
in the in the in the Orem cell and the
first name was young gravy that came to
our mind and he lives out in Minnesota
and was was in New York and we were
gonna trying to coordinate it but we
couldn't but we still are talking to
young gravy actively okay well shout out
young gravy love younger you're
listening and we know that you are yeah
he he cracks me up and it's so rich so
original and also he he uses all the
songs that I love from my like from
growing up but he's he's way younger
than than I but he knows that songs from
his mom I was gonna say well young gravy
the only thing with young gravy is by
the way great hair beautiful hair I'm
trying to draw my hair young gravy
though the only thing is we will have
him on the podcast and it's all good but
you have to understand that what he
asked for in return is he will have sex
with our mothers which is that all right
it gets good views yeah you know talk
about it I'm not gonna say no we can't
rule it out my mom our actually already
said you know as long as he's a good
practicing Catholic boy okay she'll do
it all right yeah he's gotta he's got a
good stease
um uh young great do you know that
people might not know this but before
this was the no pressure Network we we
renamed it at the last second we were
gonna call the network gravy baby we
were gonna call it gravy baby and then
we would have been promptly sued by
young gravy
baby we could always go back
I think with no pressure suits this I
think it suits us
what if we kill Joe DeRosa
then what do we continue there's a lot
of there's a lot of plots in the news of
people killing people everybody's
getting killed I know so we just right
now we just you know obviously as you
guys know we sometimes do an episode and
then it comes out a week or two later
because we just have so much fun content
but we just found out today moments ago
that they just arrested someone in the
slangs of those Idaho kids that were
killed which is horrific but so we by
the time this episode comes out it could
be out onto who it was because they're
not saying who it was but my question to
you is because 25 year old person right
from the from probably uh they said
Scranton Pennsylvania is where they
found him
shout out to Mifflin what if it's young
gravy
well that killed those kids well that's
gonna be then that's gonna be a career
taken away too soon too soon yeah
because he's just getting started this
kid yeah I mean it got to the point
where we sat on one podcast episode a
couple of weeks ago might have even been
hey babe we were thinking because nobody
knows who I said could it be Santa Claus
I don't know who the hell would they
could not find who killed those people
TT Jerry convicted criminalize many
years for 20 years said in this he said
in this I swear to God he was looking at
you know he didn't know anything about
he's watching the news he goes they
haven't found nobody yet and I was like
no he goes I guarantee with somebody
their age he goes old person ain't gonna
go in there and kill all those people
without raping them that's what he said
I swear to God I swear to God that's
what he said a lot of the kids I swear
to God I was feeding my one-year-old
daughter oatmeal
I don't judgment
yeah it's a sound argument it's a sound
dog yeah but he and he's true because he
said that that that's a young kid he
said came in and said he said I bet you
one of those girls probably didn't hook
up with him or didn't want to be with
him and then that [ __ ] killed
everybody because you see those he and
he used words he's detective detective
Jerry dude TT Jerry told me I've said
this but TT Jerry told me we want when
he got out of prison when Jerry got a
prison as you know I've talked about
he's served time with the Son of Sam he
was like Son of Sam didn't kill all
those people and then that was like a
month or two before Netflix came out
with this documentary about Son of Sam
who it said was the document was making
an argument the documentary was making
an argument he did not kill all those
people there's no way he doesn't Jerry
was like I knew he didn't kill all those
people that [ __ ] was in a cult
no yeah he knows Berkowitz yes
yes
oh [ __ ] I did want to tell you guys
about this um you know how doctor's
offices send out text greetings now to
you yeah which annoys me they'll say
like happy holidays oh God yeah so there
was one doctor's office that texted all
8 000 patients instead of the holiday
greeting that they're terminally ill
with cancer yes with a link to their
report that they have cancer I saw how
could you imagine
could you imagine getting that text
that's uh that goes against the rules
yeah what's that called
uh parent Hippocratic
uh
uh yeah you know what happened to me
once you know what happened to me once I
did not even know this I can't believe
they do that I went to a City MD I went
to just regular City MD got regular
blood work whatever so I didn't know
that somebody I got a call about two
months later from a law firm saying we
just want to let you know you've been a
victim of a whatever type of crime they
call that and I said what like what what
do you mean no I haven't and they were
like when you went did you go to citymd
on this date and I was like maybe I have
no idea you know I'm a hypochondriac I
walk in and out like it's a pizzeria
right right so so I'm always in and out
right so I got a press pass so so they
go they go well when you one of the
visits that you went to a um a person
working there
are not opened up your chart and didn't
have the authority to open up your chart
and look through your chart your medical
history and sent and we can tell took
the PDF of your chart and sent it to
another email so you your medical
records have been compromised
um and they were like would you like to
press charges on she's been fired but
would you like to press charges on her
and I thought about it probably too
quickly and I just I just said no oh you
pressed the charges I should have
pressed the charges yeah what is what is
the motive there what happened there
well they know that so what happened was
is what is because you know the the law
I said the same I said why would they do
that like is there some way they can
make money off this like is it this
scheme that happens they said after
talking to the people the doctor they
and and you know doing their own
research the girl had recognized uh me
from whatever hey babe or Chrissy chaos
or or or or the ultimate Beastmaster on
Netflix
and and and
look through my stuff and then sent my
stuff to someone so it was isolated
because it was you this person just saw
your name she knew you she was like oh I
know this person is famous or I'm a fan
then open up your medical records and
then fold it to like another friend like
probably like hey hey look look at his
cholesterol yeah yeah yeah yeah or look
he he wasn't lying about having
chlamydia right yeah dude that is that
is like a worst fear yeah it was it so I
it was interesting though like that
happening it's one of those things where
again is that a big deal is my life
radically changed I'm the type of person
even if you had my medical records and
tweeted I'd retweet them I don't give a
[ __ ] right but I did honestly get that I
did honestly feel like like that term
when you feel violated like I actually
felt like on a serious level I was like
I actually feel violated again I don't
deal with I don't care but I was like
I'm that is a violation so I wanted I
wonder if I should retroactively go back
and press
it also sounds like a lot of work for
you yeah it's a lot of things it's like
it's like so what if the whole world
knows my blood pressure's too high but
to go back to the cancer text you guys
get that text and it's real what is the
first so you're telling me there's a
contingent of those 8 000 people that
thought that they were getting a text
that they had cancer yeah or did they
understand that they just got someone
else's they all got the same text and it
didn't have it no they read it as if
they were getting a unique text to them
I think 8 000 people are just gonna I
don't know a tech mistake no like you
call that there has to be a lawsuit
because listen there was like you ever
hear about that that person uh that law
doctor's office that was doing
colonoscopy he's like routine
colonoscopies and they didn't properly
clean the colonoscopy equipment like
they never and so they did colonoscopies
for weeks with unclean materials like
you could have given someone like any
disease in the world that way so they
got sued by the text like that saying I
can't no you could sue you could sue for
um what do they call it uh emotional
damage yeah emotional emotional damage
punitive damages or something I had to
get a process and a colonosc soon it
never had either nightmare let's talk
about it I've gotten both I know you
what do you want to know I'm nervous and
I'll tell you another thing I'm nervous
for the rest of my life because whatever
surgery after even even when I was in
the morgue you know like and I was
getting fumed and uh I was in my wake
and stuff like the only thing I have to
say to you about being nervous for the
rest of your life is just the words from
Rihanna that have helped me so much Liv
be alive
oh I better sit in a paper and live your
life yeah oh come on boy can you get it
up
all right what are the Jamaican father
say to you in the back seat
the girls Jamaican guy that got out of
prison
yeah he goes um
um it goes uh uh uh what to say again
and he goes you didn't tell me he was
dating a white boy
[Laughter]
um uh but but colonoscopy let me tell
you something have you ever been put
under anesthesia I have okay for what uh
like I think uh like when I was younger
gum surgery it's a tooth extraction or
something okay but fully knocked out
yeah yeah I have in a couple times I
will take a countdown from 10 and then
you just wake up in the recovery room
like what the [ __ ] so what God was gonna
say as an adult when I got my
colonoscopy was the one and only time I
had to be put under anesthesia I want
someone to be there that I know okay I
don't I don't trust anybody well I
really feel like when I'm underneath and
I'm in a medical thing or even in my way
I just feel like people are going to do
things with my penis hip and I'll be
there pimples set up a three camera
shoot of course would you like us to
film it so we have it back up I swear to
God you can film it will they let me
film it just ask them I'll come ask him
we'll film it we'll film your
colonoscopy and guess where the people
can find it patreon that's right that's
that's it yeah but we should we should
prank them and say for your insurance
yeah I would do that as long as you
don't get like my ass and you know
nothing anything exactly with the inside
can we see the insides of you or is that
yes I don't even know if I want to see
the inside I think I think you shouldn't
be nervous about it it's something that
you do health is wealth okay and I think
that the colonoscopy and what was the
other one the endoscopy I got the
prostate exam too finger in the ass I
will it just feels very cold it does it
feels very cold I had a Russian Lady do
it feels very cold it's not a finger in
the oven yeah it's like a bulb and it's
freezing no no it's a finger though they
do the finger but then you could go I I
guess I went to the big how does she
know what the bolt how does the bulb
doesn't she feel feel for something
herself no there's some type of
instrument that was put in my ass okay
and it it it does seem a little more
to not have the dock to stick yeah
because yeah maybe maybe there is maybe
maybe I'm talking about something that's
Antiquated because does the doctor still
you mean to tell me that a doctor who
went to school for many years who makes
six figures salary and has a you know
every day that daily processes every day
they just stick their fingers up
people's asses all day long
like there's got to be a better way
right there's not a doctor that's like
every day five days a week every every
week I just my finger goes in and out of
[ __ ] of everybody that's what a
gynecologist does every day their
fingers just in their vagina yes ma'am
my other neighbor over here does that
God bless you know you're like I want to
help these people that might have colon
cancer prostitutes or whatever but you
are saying you are up front being at a
young age you're saying for the rest of
my life yeah I want to just deal with
[ __ ] this is what I've committed to
I'm gonna deal with home that's a choice
no you're gonna deal with it and and and
and listen every day 24 7 [ __ ] my
life well I always thought about that is
is is is being a doctor that's an
[ __ ] doctor not a doctor is an
[ __ ] an [ __ ] doctor that checks
out your [ __ ] is that something you
set out for something you fall into like
did you set out like you wanted to be a
plastic surgeon or a dermatologist and
things didn't work out one thing led to
another next thing you know you're the
colonoscopy right like you failed out of
one they're like what do you have left
like this [ __ ] if you want to do it
yeah some credits what do you want you
could do [ __ ] you could do feet it's
up to you yeah what are you gonna do you
want to do feed her [ __ ] and people
go [ __ ] yeah what hole would you guys
choose to be a specialist then yeah here
yep ear hole is that a person yes your
nose and throat your nose and throat
Odo laryngologist is that what it is I
think I thought it was entomologist no I
think an entomology
can you actually pull up different
titles of doctors like biologists and I
bet there's so many of them that like
you have no idea what that one what's
that person who whacks everybody's hair
what are they called dirt and uh station
and Ashton Kutcher I there's such a
choice read one out read one out see if
we could no let's see if we can play
Choice I'm gonna rip people's hair out
with rocks it's painful endocrinologist
so an endocrinologist of the endocrine
system they're working with your
hormones all right okay so that's one oh
you had to study this stuff didn't you
yeah but there's a lot of [ __ ] I don't
know okay
yeah some of these gastronologists
cardiologists okay those we know
intestines and gastrologists is who
you're going to do uh the colonoscopy
through right I think so I had to drink
something that drink let me tell you
something let me tell you something
when you're getting your colonoscopy
drinking that potion you have to drink
the day before the people at home do
yourself a favor motion's a fun word set
up set up on laptop in front of the
toilet bowl because when that thing hits
it hits just watch get ready to watch
them hey babes get you're gonna watch
about four or five Babys in a row no
[ __ ] your brains out the entire time
it does not stop you have to I and
listen just a pro tip
whether you get driven there are you
professional at this I'm professional
where and get get yourself an adult pair
of Depends an adult diaper no and where
stop it dude are you putting me on I
swear to God no I'm not putting you on
terrible no here you might [ __ ] yourself
here's the thing is because what they
don't tell you is how far is the
hospital from your house the day of and
what time is it are you doing okay
because if you're getting an afternoon
one then you got to wait around all day
don't worry about shit's creek that's it
without a paddle yes without it so what
you what you want to do is try to get a
morning one as early as you can six
seven a.m but what they don't tell you
is yes you'll you know you drink this
potion and then you gotta you know it's
got to clean out your guts so they can
take a peek and call in and all that but
they don't but it depends how long it
takes for you to get from your house to
the hospital because you will [ __ ] your
pants in that car so wear the adult
diaper but I I I dude it cut it is
uncontrollable it is almost like you're
an involuntarily so what happens when I
arrive at the hospital with loaded dipe
you take it off you get a wet wipe you
take it off so I walk in I say can I use
the bed I walk in smelling like [ __ ] and
then say I need the bathroom right away
and I remove an adult diaper and I I
everybody's [ __ ] their pants in that
waiting room no
no if you can if you can
say say that you would like to the 7 A.M
this happens to everybody every you can
get you can't get the tube up there if
you don't take the potion the right way
and you don't [ __ ] your brains out and
evacuate your bowels then when they look
up in your in your ass they're gonna
it's just gonna be covered in [ __ ] and
they can't take a look at your colon and
all these other things because they're
looking for cancer and polyps but if
they're if you can't a [ __ ] covered
polyp you can't it has to be clean as a
whistle so you got to take that potion I
knew a guy I had a friend who took the
potion on the they messed up their uh
colonoscopy so he took the potion [ __ ]
his brains out showed up they like your
appointments next week
[Music]
[Laughter]
still bad
I think that's a double whammy when you
say Without a Paddle I think it's
doubling down right because you're in a
creek full of [ __ ] right that's bad
right without a paddle you're not going
anywhere I think the only person can
answer that question is Eugene leaver
Catherine O'Hara correct those are the
only two that can answer because if
you're actually with a paddle it's bad
but you have a paddle right yeah I think
yeah I'd always opt to have a paddle in
any situation but like I don't I'm gonna
be honest with you if you gave me a boat
and a paddle and you said get yourself
to safety I don't know that I would know
how to paddle a boat the right way
paddling is a lot harder yeah than it
looks yeah yeah yeah because yeah
because you have to really get a rhythm
going otherwise you just keep like going
all you ever see a racing team
dude I was in like Prague I think or
somewhere and I was on the my hotel was
on the river okay and they were racing
they were like those racing what do they
call those people [ __ ] but like
they're like you know like 10 ripped
guys oh yeah rowers yeah like a rowing
team yeah dude they're going like like
50 miles an hour it's it's it's
unbelievable to see like they just and
it just racing up and down up and down
up and down
it just seems like something that I
wouldn't want to be doing would you say
Prague is a must-see must you have to
see products I loved it and if I don't
go see Prague I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] I
would go I would make it a point to go
in your lifetime right it was one of my
favorite places and you only spent time
in Prague or was Prague part of a bigger
trip that trip Prague was part of a trip
to Greece as well got it but you could
go to Prague for a week and that's my
destination a week you ever been to
Sicily no you want to go I've only been
to the America Sinatra's got a trip
really
the nights are getting longer but the
breeze isn't the only thing that's
getting stiff yeah that's right this
episode is sponsored by bluetooth guys
we all know that confidence can take you
far in life that's especially true in
the bedroom especially when it's time to
step up to the plate that's where
Bluetooth comes in folks with Bluetooth
you're going to be excited to see the
mailman because not only is your package
arriving but your package is going to
arrive as well you know what I'm saying
that was in their copy it's not my joke
Bluetooth tablets are made in the USA
and prepared and shipped direct to your
door in a discreet package may be very
discreet even though you got a nice big
package yeah it's discreet yeah your
neighbors are not going to know what you
choose to do with your and when I say
choose no pun intended the process is
simple too all you do is go to
bluetooth.com to sign up you can solve
with one of their licensed medical
providers and once you're approved proof
you'll receive your prescription within
days the best is this all done online
and no visits to the doctor no awkward
conversations no waiting in line at the
pharmacy okay tablets are made in the
good old us of a they're prepared and
shipped direct to your door okay listen
it's time to get off your couch and back
to work and if your tool needs an
upgrade
bluetooth.com's for you so if you could
benefit from extra confidence when it's
time to perform chew it and do it have
better sex and we've got a special deal
for our listeners try Bluetooth free
when you use our promo code hey babe at
checkout just pay five bucks for
shipping that's bluetooth.com promo code
hey babe to receive your first month
free visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
and we thank Bluetooth for sponsoring
the podcast
listen ding dong [ __ ] I just used two
nights ago and I'm not joking me neither
I love doordash and even though I know
you talked about intermittent fasting
what fits perfect in My fasting window
getting food from places like doordash
doordash is first of all it literally
it's got everything I mean I all you do
is download the app get doordash I mean
you have all the uh you have all like
the major you know Chipotle
Etc this is how every night goes that
we're not cooking in my house my girl my
girl goes what do you want to eat
tonight I'm like I'm not sure if you
just text me like a restaurant from a
link from doordash I look at it I scroll
I pick what I want because we're in the
same account she goes in
we push a button it comes I love it and
I get I get food from like across the
other end of town yeah that doesn't
deliver to me and they come and listen
whether you need last minute school
supplies and impromptu dinner or Flash
FL fresh flowers for that special
occasion door Dash oh I didn't know that
yes doordash does it all now oh you can
get dinner household essentials and
everything you want doordash is like I
got you oh that's next it was already
good this is next level dude that's like
having a personal assistant yes yes
because listen along with with the
restaurants you love you can now get
groceries and the essential items
delivered with doordash drinks snacks
household items in under an hour over
300 000 Partners doordash has you can
support your neighborhood go-to's or
just your favorite National restaurants
like Popeyes Chipotle in the Cheesecake
Factory that's what I love about
doordash they got something for
everybody yes with doordash there is a
neighborhood of good in every order uh
truly truly this is something I use all
the time for a limited time our
listeners can get 50 off up 20 value I
might have to sign up for this myself do
it you should and zero zero dollars in
delivery fees when you download the
doordash app and enter the code hey babe
2023 I'm doing that tonight before I use
it again that's 50 off up to a 20 value
and zero dollars in delivery fees when
you download the doordash app in the app
store and enter the code hey babe two
zero two three don't forget
that's code hey babe two zero two three
for fifty percent off up to a twenty
dollar value a zero dollar delivery fees
with doordash subject to change in terms
of long-term Supply
okay okay hello fresh yes with hello
fresh you get farm fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and seasonal recipes
delivered right to your doorstep by the
way I mean if you watch us you already
know this but if there's a new listener
if you forgot hello Fresh then we're
gonna re-up you here skip trips to the
grocery store and count on hello fresh
to make home cooking easy fun and
affordable that's why it's America's
number one meal kit now when it's time
for the game Home gate like a pro with a
limited time winning assortment of
snacks apps and shareable sweets
available at the hello Fresh Market
that's good football fans treat friends
and fans to delicious barbecue baby back
ribs chocolate chip brownies and
everything in between yummy yummy in my
tummy skip the snowy slept to the
grocery store and stock up on snacks
size and desserts and more at hello
Fresh Market simply add those Staples
and sweets to your weekly order and
they'll arrive at your doorstep along
with your meals now that's smart that's
smart so then not just delivering now
just pre-portioned ingredients for you
to cook but they're also an online
grocer hello fresh is one of the best
company these that I've ever that we've
ever had the pleasure of working with
here and they are smart but tell me how
this makes sense this this this this is
the part we don't this is what I just
don't
how is this stuff away from you it's not
too good listen to this hellofresh.com
if you go right now to hellofresh.com
slash hey babe21 and use the code hey
babe21 they're gonna give you 21 free
meals plus free shipping let me say that
to you again and again
hellofresh.com hey babe21 put in the
promo code hey babe21 21 free meals plus
free shipping they are giving it away I
mean people people in like Guatemala and
Peru should all be doing this why the
hell not this is going to help solve a
crisis at some point give the food away
I don't mean I don't know if that's they
need food there but 100
and it needs to be Peru's number one
meal kit correct all right that's it
that's it go to hellofresh.com hey
babe21 use code hey babe21 for free
meals plus free shipping it is highly
recommended hellofresh America's number
one meal kit I've only been to Amalfi
Coast uh like four years ago whatever
but I'm thinking about going when I get
when we finish filming in a month I I'm
thinking about going at least two trips
one tropical okay okay Costa Rica if you
want it's there yeah and then I think
maybe uh Italy or or London again my
birth control what is it birth control
medicine which we don't have my medicine
I did want to go sell a spot I did want
to go back to what you guys would do if
you found out you were terminally ill
like what's your your first day of
knowing
are you trying to spiral me right now I
go to two therapists about this like
like don't do that I don't know I I
think if there's a freedom to it I would
kind of be like okay I think it's a
prison not a freedom I don't know I wish
I wish I could be that person that's
like inspiring and down to the last
minute they're inspiring and they're
they're fighting and they're hopeful but
I don't I think I would fold like a
house of cards I think I think start
taking psychedelics I would do that yeah
dude that's when you do the Ayahuasca
that's when you do The Silo side like
you feel like you're not there though
but it's but it's all it doesn't it's
not you ever go to a party you get
wrecked and you're like I wasn't even I
don't even remember it that's how I felt
by the way I would want to savor the
moments even though I'm depressed test
that's how I felt this year for the
first time ever at Christmas with my
family it was so overwhelming and and
over stimulating for myself for my
family for the kids everybody opening up
all these gifts and you know like I
realized like all the adults everybody
getting gifts all we did was three hours
open up we ate and opened up gifts but
we barely ever talked like we didn't
talk at all so I was like why shouldn't
let the children open the gifts it's
about them but no gifts for the adults
let's just talk and drink and eat and
feel a connection like I felt at folkats
with my neighbors exactly yeah congrats
yes when you had the soup yes uh I will
tell you right now and I swear to God
100 True every year that's pretty much
my experience right this year for this
year for the first time ever we said all
right we'll do a secret Santa for the
adults are you getting one person right
otherwise everyone was getting everyone
I had to get like 15 adults 15 kids like
right so one person we we did the the
adults exchanged like at like seven
o'clock like before dinner like one you
go I got you and we watch you open yours
okay he got you you'd watch it we did
that it took like a half hour and then
just the adults just the adults the kids
were not involved and then later on we
all just sat there and watched the kids
open open theirs which is normally it's
just what you just said it's everyone
passing everyone you don't even see
who's open and what it's just pure
Mayhem and we we changed it yeah you're
walking around with a garbage bag
putting the wrapping paper in the
garbage bag here's a pet peeve of mine
okay because my family likes to do that
they like to open up a bag and as soon
as someone rips the thing they put it in
the bag with its bags all over the place
and everyone's well give me a capacity
of it and they put in the bag I hate
that I love a love having it look like
literally
uh like a like Obama fun yes like like
Santa Dropped a Bomb on this place
exactly as an Isis everything yeah like
like I was just looks like Sarajevo in
the living room yes like I just wanted
to look like everything's everywhere
like this this wrapping paper about that
all almost like you're walking through
it like you're in a ball pit it's like
it's like knee-high yeah yeah that yeah
I just feel like that's so far and then
the next time you do a sweep yeah you
put everything in the bed you could
listen the truth is the matter if the
kids are under that you don't even know
what the kids are they want to clean up
that wrapping paper in 15 minutes you'll
clean up with a big Hefty bag right you
know when other what other time are you
gonna have your entire home in three
feet of wrapping paper it's hilarious
it's great yeah I I think it really like
it makes it like special to me that's
interesting though that you said for the
first time ever you did what I first we
said it out loud like this is this is
because every year that was our
experience well it takes balls to be in
my at least in my family in my
experience the first adult to say get
your whole family in a group text say I
don't want to give you a gift anymore
well
it up to me I love Christmas Is My Jam
because I love giving gifts I love it I
look forward to it I thought early right
I like I take yeah this whole year
you're a Christmas guy serious about
that [ __ ] when do you start what's the
earliest you've ever started with a
Christmas gift purchase and wrap okay so
if I've come across something or like oh
this person would love that if it's
really far out I'll probably just buy it
and give it to them as a just because
gift right but if it's within like six
months I might be like oh they would
love that I'll either note it or I'll
get it I'll put it in my like in my like
garage like my utility right whatever
but um usually I like to start like by
November 1st wow but this year was hard
because she would get my own rules I was
dead yeah I should follow my own rules
because the last
three-ish years or so I have I have been
mid-December starting and it's been it's
been to my demise which that literally
that only raises the stress level it
raises because now it's two weeks out
time and I didn't put enough thought
into this and I don't like giving a gift
that's just like
here this is a tie you know I don't like
that you want to be like I this is
tailor-made
oh yeah yeah because you're like I can't
oh yeah I I I think that that's why I
get stressed out because I never ever
start November and I am always getting
someone
a gift that really had no thought and
this Christmas I did probably the the
stupidest thing
I got Jasmine
the girlfriend mother my children I got
her her gifts which were very expensive
beautiful gifts that she wanted she was
like this is what I want it's a big if
this is what I want
I got it got it for her immediately
ordered it took a week on it and then
gave it to her right then and there
about two weeks before Christmas yeah on
Christmas day she had nothing to open
for me yeah you know and it was one of
those things where as much as we said
was just about the kids oh wait you
didn't get anything
no she gave she gave me my gifts
for me for me no no she she I gave her
gifts two weeks before even though they
were very expensive and then she wasn't
part of the the the whole Fanfare yes
and she's just been for the past three
weeks just little here and there just
little next like you know that she
didn't get anything to open up on
Christmas and I said to my dad I
explained to my dad because my dad's
like always on my side I was like
explaining I was like you know I bought
you I was like this really expensive
gifts like thousands of dollars worth of
gifts like really beautiful
stuff and you know it was two weeks
before Christmas and she's upset that I
didn't get anything on Christmas and he
was like you should have got her
something open on Christmas
he was like he was like you should have
just did anything a bottle of wine a
card he was like I was again but I got
her all this money worth of gifts he's
like you gotta She's Gotta open
something whose idea was it to give it
that early hers she wanted it she wanted
it right away I I don't whenever that
happened I get like something early for
like whoever with my girlfriend whoever
and they're like I want like can I just
think give it now I'm like no no no
absolutely not wait my mom too like my
dad my mom's like Oh can I just I'm like
no no even if you knew even if that
person said this is exactly what I want
you're still not opening it until
Christmas that's when you're opening it
now and you could live with the
anticipation which makes it better I
have a question for you guys I hate the
first three months of the year I can't
get through it what gets you guys
through the first what now why don't you
like the first three months of the year
because I kind of like the first three
months of the year nothing to look
forward to the weather sucks I just hate
myself well I look you break backwards
to look forward to take it back
take it back and and
um and and St Patrick's Day you don't
like it stinks I like to go watch the
couple President's Day Valentine's Day
Sucks Valentine's Day is your birthday
day before oh it's not wild Super Bowl
you're 15th 13th okay yeah Super Bowl
that stinks too that's just about eating
yeah I enjoy the Super Bowl because I
usually have a little thing at the house
right yeah but I I hate January February
I think of the worst three months you're
going to interesting the holidays are
over it's frigid it's great people
usually feel fat on January 1st usually
people wake up January 1st feeling
really fat and they start up and you are
feeling fat and Bloated yes usually and
then March comes March is a real piece
of [ __ ] it's it's it's in like a lion
out like a lamb yeah yeah yeah and
that's all I know all the rain starts
and like the humidity and stuff I can't
stand the rain against my window
do you feel like the year doesn't start
till April
I might even say may wow it's gonna be
me
with what you said um that's interesting
balls someone had balls you know what
just had I was at a I was at the like
the local supermarket or whatever and I
was getting like uh uh uh ShopRite no
it's like it's like like a Mickey's like
a like a like a local one okay
Associated it's like a smaller one right
whatever I was getting I was getting I
was getting was it fruit or something
and I put the thing on I was like and I
was like and they charged the wrong
thing it was an older lady
who's an older lady and I go oh I think
that that was this price and she's like
no then that was yesterday and I was
like oh well the the sign's still up and
she's like yeah that's wrong I was like
so if I would have came yesterday I
would have got the price and she goes if
my aunt had bold she'd be my uncle
[Laughter]
she was like 70. I was also like you
still have an aunt
my hand had balls she'd leave well I
want to go to that Supermarket I was
like why we why did this was a sharp
turn from Clementine so you just paid
you just paid the full price the extra
money yeah I was like all right yeah
that is an interesting thing you bring
up though pimp about how but what the
worst three months because I would
assume because of the cold as well it's
in the New York Northeast going on but
but in January February March to our
friends who live in Miami do our friends
who live in Australia who it's the
summertime do they feel that do
California feel that have you ever had a
big life moment in the first three
months of the year I have no idea I mean
you were born in the first three months
of the year
your life began you're right it might be
a New York thing right so let me ask you
this also from New York though what's
the best three months is it what's the
best 360 succession of months I think
it's August and then August September
October I think September October
November or October November December I
think I gotta go no I gotta go October
November December the summer August
sucks
because it's too hot but you know I love
going in the pool I love the getting uh
getting getting dark late uh you know I
love those barbecues people are more
prone to go out and do stuff and I get
all that the beach whatever you know I'm
not a beach guy but at the end of the
day
how can you compete with October
November December in New York City it's
about 60 degrees Halloween fun
Thanksgiving fun got the trifecta of the
biggest holidays Christmas coming my
birthday is in that time no no on top of
that my birthday is in which I uh but
also not even my birthday I love the
changing of the leaves you love the
changes it's awesome I love getting
ready for fall I love getting ready for
fall I love when that first crisp brisk
air hits and you're like uh oh breaking
out the sweatshirt yeah right on the I
will say what is usually really nice too
though is in like late April usually
early May in New York when it's starting
to get that warm spring that first
spring night when it's like yo it's 70
degrees yeah and it's nice let's get a
rough size it's not sweating and then
you start to think about but then
usually what happens to me in that time
period And I will take a moment talk to
you about intermittent fasting after I
explain this is is it is is usually at
that time I would always be depressed
rest around April May because it would
remind me seasonal depression you didn't
you didn't do what you said supposed to
do January 1st in time for something you
are not shredding for summer you're now
now I feel like I'm wrapping gifts
December 15th again how am I going to
get my body unwrapped right right in the
two weeks that it's gonna take and then
I give up and I have a fat guy summer
and I'm in the pool with the shirt on
but not this year thanks to zero fasting
app yes I I I've now eaten a 16 to 18
hour window uh my body uh while while if
I have my feeding time I work I I eat in
my feeding window and I exercise while
I'm in a fasted fat burning State
um and what's your feeding window right
now my feeding window right now
typically ten to six but on a day like
this it's 12 12.
[ __ ] you're not having a bite
after 6 p.m what time do you go to bed
ten oh that's early okay but so you only
get you only have four hours to hold off
no but listen how how many how many
nights in the beginning did you go to
bed were you stomach growling before you
broke through that it was a lot it was
hard but now but but I will say on the
nights when we have shows like say we
you know might have two shows a seven
and a nine or eight and a ten what are
you doing there those days I I eat at
six and I just drink water I just drink
water through and I don't drink alcohol
either you don't drink alcohol you can't
the alcohol breaks the fast but I do
give myself one night a week it's it was
the holiday so you know I haven't been
as diligent with the fasting but since
January 1st it's one night a week
typically Saturdays typically sat Friday
night's the hardest one because you're
like Friday fun let loose that's the one
that I gotta says Friday
um with you oh that's the Cure Tuesday
Thursdays uh make love something just
Sunday uh Friday I'm in Love that's
right so but Saturday Sunday
I don't care if Monday's blue Tuesday is
gray and Wednesday to Thursday I don't
care about you it's Friday Hey Monday
you could fall apart Tuesday Wednesday
break my heart Thursday it doesn't even
start it's Friday I'm in Love and in My
fasting window yes
Saturday is when I kind of I got to
break free yes yes Freddie Mercury yes
wow so and then you do anything you want
or no I typically do anything I want the
here's the big Improvement I need to
make because I have been now stalled I
mean stalled like now you have to know
you're right you plateaued I'm stalled
right now with my weight loss like like
patreon.com Christy comedy stalled and
and even losing so I so so I I I what I
do what I have to to do now is make the
effort and and that's why losing weight
and getting healthy and all that it
comes in increments is I've now pretty
good at 16 to 18 hours no fasting I've
even gotten multiple times I've gotten
to a 24 hour fast but so you don't eat I
I have gotten to 24 hours twice unless
is that something you're trying to
achieve well it was like oh I got to 20
hours and I'm because when you drink
water because here's the science behind
it is you don't really have to eat you
don't really have to eat food for 28
days you your body can sustain as long
as you're giving it water so I'm always
drinking water I try to drink as much
water as I can you can drink water
coffee and green tea what about
nutrients so no that I'm not doing that
all the time I'm saying no but I mean
just in general I mean you could you're
not supposed to go without food for 28
days right yeah you're not supposed to
but my point is that like when you're so
hungry but you ate eight hours like a
wolf hungry like Michelle wolf
so I'm hungry
I what I do is is I just say to myself
what you know if if the human body can
go 28 days I can go another five hours
without eating even though I'm rap she
hungry and just drink water and I'll be
fine
so but but what I have to do now is now
in that fasting window because what I
was been doing I'd be like I'm fasting
even in that eight hours six hour
feeding window I'm eating [ __ ] I'm
eating pizza I was gonna ask you that in
the within your fasting window are you
eating healthy some most of the time no
but I've still so yeah you should and
you still lose it you got pizza yeah
yeah you can't go Pizza ham pizza right
all right you have a slice yeah if
you're still eating over 3 000 calories
right you're done right but even that
even the science and that is still with
the fasting even if you over ate which
they're not saying to do that but even
if you did that you would still if you
give your body and digestive system over
16 hours of just no food it still starts
to eat its fat cells it's still you so
so but now because I've reached the
platoon even went up a bit in weight and
I just don't like the way my body looks
sometimes I'm like I got to now in that
fasting window eat healthy in the
fasting window and I'm gonna try now for
the new year which has begun two weeks
ago the only it's only just begun
what I'm going to try to do is in that
fasting window for Monday to Friday eat
very healthy within the fancy window and
then Saturday lose my [ __ ] mind I'll
eat ass
Fridays
by the way do you see the show White
Lotus yes of course White Lotus season
one yeah you will never see this in
television or movies there is a gay ass
eating scene that like right in the
beginning right what are I think it's
towards the end of the season oh is it I
thought it was in the beginning oh yeah
you're right by the way White Lotus I
liked White Lotus season one and season
two found myself missing the characters
from season one in season two I wanted
season one characters in season two the
guy the Australian gay receptionist is
the best character in that whole show
and I love White Lotus I love that and
actually see because here's the thing
because I [ __ ] up the Christmas not
opening not well you didn't well well
because because but I felt so guilty you
know for Jasmine's birthday morning
Johnson's birthday which by the way is
in April that's when life is
his name her birthday is April
April in April this is going to be
surprising don't [ __ ] tell her tweet
her little pieces [ __ ] don't do it don't
do it is I got
four nights in that Resort in Sicily
that they film white load a season to it
Steve Dominican Palace I I got it yeah
why don't you just go to Costa Rica for
free
we could but I'm going I got a direct
flight to Palermo and then we're going
to drop you're announcing this on this
yeah
I think he's going to get back I want to
trust myself
literally everything White Lotus did in
season two when they took a day trip to
nodo yeah what I'm doing the white
loaded experience Palermo you're gonna
do the White Lotus experience I hope you
meet a pack of fun games yes we will you
know what I mean so uh don't tell her
because it's a surprise yeah do you know
that my my lady's parents just came back
from that Resort exact Resort what did
they say they
loved it did they go because of White
Lotus and they were going they went
before they went before the white load
so they've always been there I've heard
the prices have tripled from white
lights
I mean you're paying them they say they
said unbelievable amazing one of the
best trips and best places they've ever
stayed I swear to god wow and they just
stayed there they didn't go on by chance
and then they came home and then White
Lotus thought and they were like oh my
God
I will tell you in White Lotus they
filmed in four locations they made it
look like one but one of the other
locations is right across the street
directly from the main location okay so
here's the thing do you know that I
stayed in the White Lotus from season
one you stayed there before it was what
before I they before I saw a white load
of season one you know it's Hawaii yeah
yeah in Hawaii yeah yeah and you went
there the whole the whole Resort they
walked around I was like we were there I
was there for a week is that a must-see
in Hawaii is that Resort that was a very
nice it was a four seasons did you
really have to take the boat there like
you have to take a boat there did I take
a boat or did you drive because they
make it seem like you got to take no I
think we drove did you have to take the
boat to the one did you uh did your
lady's parents have to take the boat to
the one and it's just
so because a lot of here's what a lot of
people do and here's what I'm not gonna
do here's what I'm not prepared to do
anymore okay if I'm gonna go to a place
in Europe okay or any destination rather
than trying to fit everything into a
schedule and try to get all these things
done I'd rather go experience one thing
and experience all of it so rather than
trying to go to Sicily Italy Greece I'm
just going to go to Sicily for five days
I'm just staying in one place and I'm
going directly there and coming directly
home I I okay now tell me now debate
that with me okay
so when I went to the Amalfi Coast I was
there for four nights and I just stayed
there and it was awesome because you
really and then you went back and that
came back to New York but I will tell
you like whoo if you really want to see
Italy I don't know how you're gonna go
there and back and there and back and
there and back and there and back and
you know what I'm saying right because
there's so many [ __ ] places you want
to see right and I might I'm telling you
I I'm I'm thinking about booking a trip
there and we're gonna and you know what
I was thinking well or just well
possibly there because her her mom was
like you have to go right and we want to
go there so possibly there but also we
were going to like hop around a little
bit I don't know how long could stay I
don't know if I how long I have but I I
in theory I fully fully fully agree with
you right fully agree with you like you
were talking about I just want to go to
people on the go on the go on the go no
no why do that why do that I just want
to go and experience it and show I don't
want to just sit on the beach like they
did in White Lotus I want to go around
yeah I want to go around and see this
place in that place but I want to just
be in one place I don't want to be like
now I got to pack my bags and go to
another country you know it's kind of
like like when we do our comedy this is
my new philosophy even though it'll be
like you know less money but I'm
starting to think quality of life
quality over quantity I'm like okay if I
go to Miami which I'll be in March 31st
font on Blue rather than like the show
is almost sold out rather than adding a
show at the hotel yeah there's there's
like they're they're doing comedy there
now so yeah doing a show there uh it's
almost sold out um a few tickets left
but but rather I could add a shell they
were like would you like to add a shell
and I said no even though I know it's
more money and whatever and more money
for the time I said why not I'll still
be done with my show by nine o'clock
have a great time not have to worry
about putting a second one I say I'll be
done by nine I can live my life I'll
come back to Miami Miami's not going
anywhere right you know I I you know I
mean it could go underwater with global
warming yeah but that's not a question
for me that's up to Elon Musk correct
and and I and I've said I will come back
and my agent was like most Comics don't
think like that most people don't think
like that they want to get all the money
a time but right he said I can
understand if you're you want to do this
for the Long Haul yeah
we can play it like that but you know
you just will make less money and I'm
like that's fine because I'll get I
won't have the stress of of the second
show I know dude the second show is so
that's where the stress is it's always
like I'm is it gonna sell am I I got to
keep now I gotta reprode it pushing it
yeah yeah so I'm like I'll come back to
Miami if there's a demand for me and I
sold out the first Show with two months
left in the city where the heat is on
all night
welcome to Miami I'm gonna come back to
Miami bam no slap you in the face like
Will Smith
isn't that him getting jiggy with it
yeah isn't welcome to Miami Will Smith
yeah
Brian Regan has a great joke I love
Brian Regan he goes uh he goes out he
goes I want to I want to open up a
second he goes I want to have a second
basketball team in Miami he goes in when
the reporters come up to me and be like
what's the name of your new franchise
I'm gonna say well it's not the heat
it's the humidity
[Laughter]
what a great joke
it's so funny that's a perfect joke baby
with rare condition born with over half
of his body covered in hair that's an
alive fully well oh my God yeah and
that's crazy oh my God you know what
that baby needs manscaped
[Laughter]
oh my god oh this is so sad full head of
hair and the full full thick lushes and
hair continues down the neck then down
the neck and all the way down the back
did you guys see that like there's a guy
in Spain I think who's famous they call
him The Wolf Man and he's kind of that's
it oh that is so sad it's weird with the
human body is capable of so they're
gonna have to they have to shave them
every day can you even shave a baby
that's such sensitive skin you could
shave it baby
I don't think you can edit that clip out
of context I don't think
yeah a baby's skin is so sensitive right
that's that's the whole body right
they're gonna you can't take a razor to
it you can't use a chemical you can't
use a chemical now to be like that can a
baby get sunburned how's that happen oh
my God why do you think maybe can't get
sunburn I think you would want to hide
it from the Sun oh no yeah no oh I'm
sorry that skin doesn't hit the sun oh
yeah SPF 100 you put on a hat you put
them under an umbrella yeah no when you
bring a baby to if you bring a baby to
the beach you're bringing like NASA
level like tens like it is crazy I don't
know why people take babies to the beach
oh dude you haven't oh this is sad but
dude Google sunburn baby Google sunburn
parents that don't like I've seen like
toddlers at least with like you know
when you get the red line you know what
I mean to watch a baby in so much pain
like that oh my god oh I didn't want to
see like a yeah all right I didn't want
to see a baby that's got [ __ ] up like
that blister I'm at like on the beach
like a toddler on the beach that took
too much sun not like a baby in the
hospital because yeah pimp is showing us
videos of babies in gauze pads and like
in Burn units from the Sun
um I I I I yeah the the baby to the
beach if you're someone who has a young
baby you like the beach don't like the
beach even even with even even with
feeling better about myself I'm not a
beach guy I'm a pool guy yeah I'm a pool
guy I'm I'm an outdoor guy now I do like
the white sand beach where the crystal
clear not rough water I like that but
the days of like when we were little
like building a sand castle or just
sitting there burying yourself or that
kind of thing with sand in every single
part of you yeah get Sands in the butt
oh good almost like driving home I'm
sanding the fight I would have to I
would have to pull over and just open up
my button with the Sandpoint I I also
being a parent you know when my you know
I got I got 12 7 and one and a half now
my one in half world you know runs all
over you I'm literally just defending
them from getting in the water for six
hours getting burnt on every part of my
body it is not fun at all get them in
the pool give them some floaties there's
no sharks there's no waves there's no
condoms there's it's just nothing
there's just the kids are in the [ __ ]
pool and it's easier and even you know
Jazzy's Puerto Rican she loves the beach
I'm like well then I'll get you a
Sandbox okay I'm not we're going to sit
in this pool
sand feature get why not what would you
suggest you can do it you know what do
you mean you could just like you build
like a bocce court you build you you get
like a you know maybe like a six eight
inches high you build a perimeter in
wood and you make a legitimate sandbox
make it about you know seven feet by
eight feet or something like that so you
can put a chair in there and then in
your own yard you can go in the sand lay
down take the sun put your feet in the
sand and it's it's not like it's a big
piece of the yard and you get yourself a
cover though okay because you don't want
wind kicking up and throwing I don't
need that but if you're in it and then
you just and then you have a nice hand
but here's my question will that when
the kids jump in the pool with their
Sandy chicken cutlet feet are they is
that going to then clog my pool drain
and then do I have another ish yeah you
will I was thinking it more for you guys
not for the kids you know what I did I I
I I I
um I got a uh uh you know you know a lot
of people right now you know if you have
a pool whatever is above ground in
ground everybody wants like you know
like like a like a slide like a like a
you know they want to spend all this
money on a slide I got an inflatable
slide pool slide is one of the best
creative inventions ever made what do
you think you think poolside is up there
oh my God yeah yeah you ever see these
luxury vacation
accounts with the Yachts that have the
slide going off the back of the yacht
just walking into the or those those
those like little Huts
when the person got stuck in the slide
off the cruise ship they were stuck
that'd have to be terrifying you're
literally I'm claustrophobic so that
would what about the guy oh because you
know you've been you when you know when
the time when you were passed away what
about the guy who fell off the Carnival
Cruise Ship and survived in the water
for 18 hours dude he okay so I was dead
from November 2nd
to December 28th right so so so so in
that time frame some guy got blacked out
drunk on a Carnival Cruise he said he
remembers being at the bar the next
thing you know the next thing he
remembers he wakes up he's in the middle
of the ocean in Pitch Black by himself
floating has no didn't the splash didn't
even wake him up he is just in the ocean
by himself he stays alive for 15 hours
and is rescued by the Coast Guard alive
the entire 20 hours he was in the water
and he fell off the boat fighting a
guard because he wanted to vape yeah
because he fought a guard that's not
real that's not real that's not real so
the guard watched him go over and then
didn't call for help I mean I think they
tried to help I mean wouldn't you what
do you do that do you hit the brakes on
the cruise ship I don't think you can
you just keep going
I well I think you did you drop a pin I
I don't know I actually don't know how
you would do it I'm that guard and I'm
like oh [ __ ]
is that guard in trouble
I mean he threw somebody overboard I
mean also you think you think it's do
you think that's the um do you think
that's the cruise goer's fault or the
guard's fault well they will they be
video on the news of him almost blackout
drunk yeah he's being a piece of [ __ ]
yeah he was dancing yeah I mean I don't
know if he's a piece of [ __ ] but he's
drunk as hell right but the guard I
wonder if like the guard should know not
even to tussle with him in that state
but who knows what happened because he
wanted to Vape on any of the crew on all
the cruises how does he not freeze to
death get eaten by something well the
water was warm enough though I think the
water was just warm enough because it
was in Miami or the South it was very
warm that crucial infested 20 hours in
shark infested border shark infested
water yep
oh
yep yeah has he done a post interview
yeah what did he say
what do you like kick the shark and he
he was actually I'm sure he kicked the
shot bro I kick I just yeah you could
say anything yeah I begged a mermaid
they played the b-roll and said you sure
you weren't drunk and he was ah yeah
yeah because I fell off God help me I'm
fine I mean you talk about he could be
dehydrated also he's drunk right now he
lost 20 pounds
what do you mean overnight he lost a
pound an hour
from just Treading Water there's your
diet
you take a vape and you just leap off
the side of a cruise ship here here's
the diet you you have you need to be
ready for something tomorrow night yeah
you have me eat in a six hour feeding
window then you throw me over the
overboard on a ship that that's what you
do he lost 20 pounds just treading water
oh it's got to be hard he's also
treading the whole time so he's
dehydrated he hasn't eaten it's pitch
black behind you there's no lights out
there he's hungover fighting sharks
this guy was this guy was supposed to
live there's no way he wasn't supposed
to live what is he gonna do with his he
should run for president
he honestly he should he is hey have you
had a cruise ship are you just you can't
stop of course you can well no no why
wouldn't they stop drop the anchors
getting a dinghy and go get him because
it must not have been the security guard
must have gone into a tussle with him
and then he went and fell off security
got in a tussle but cruise ship
officials notified the ghosts tussle's a
fun word the Coast Guard at 2 30 p.m on
Thanksgiving Day 14 hours since he was
last seen yeah so he wasn't seen for
hours
it happened on Thanksgiving yeah a
Thanksgiving Cruise what happened would
you read that again uh Crews they had
notified the Coast Guard of him missing
and about the situation at 2 30 p.m so
he was already overboard 14 hours well
how does anyone know what Tommy went
overboard
curious one why did they decide to wait
that's a curious case the Benjamin
Button right there was he with people on
the cruise
and his family didn't look for him for
14 hours
no cruise ship officials didn't know let
the authorities know for 14 hours they
thought he was missing on the boat maybe
yeah they were probably searching oh
that's that's what's Wild that's wild
dude I I mean I would I would die I
would think within the hour
right away I think it sucked underneath
the boat and get chopped up by the
propeller yeah I'm always scared of that
isn't there some type of centrifuge
going on 100 there's got to be but I
would also be like
this is it for me like I there's no way
that in the Pitch Black in the middle of
the ocean of sharks think about
something touching your feet you're
drunk right you're drunk you can't see
this in front of you nothing you can't
slack of the water underneath you no you
you you're you're in Pittsburgh no one's
you you don't think anyone's coming no
you don't know who so you fell off you
don't know when you fell off you don't
know how you felt at any moment an
animal is gonna come bring you on
YouTube in the ocean in the dark drunk
and you tread for 20 hours and then
someone sees you you don't even know
which way to go and you're also watching
the only light source in the whole ocean
slowly go away
[ __ ] that that's the scariest thing I've
ever heard of in my entire life in Open
Water
dude I I
think about that right so he has to
think that odds are
99.9 he's gonna die right but he's just
not giving up right so that means for 20
hours it was a prolonged state of I'm
about to die right so he was thinking
I'm I'm probably about to die for 20
straight hours right every moment you
know you know like every moment you're
like something can bite me I might run
out of energy I I I I wouldn't what am I
doing here like right how am I am I
gonna drown am I gonna get eaten like
I'm about to die how's it going to
happen imagine thinking that for every
second for 20 hours straight in the
pitch black while you're drunk and
dehydrated oh my God and then another
boat it says here another boat that was
just a cargo ship was passing and saw a
guy in the water screaming and called
the Coast Guard
so they didn't even stop for him
I don't think they I don't think there's
any stopping a boat you're not going to
Anchor a huge cargo ship yeah and how
can they walk no way to get him why not
jump get get the there's got to be
someone on board there's an emergency
they could jump in the water it also
could have been like they already passed
and they just saw a dude screaming
they're like I did you know who knows
what how far so
they don't look at a spot in a month so
he lived because another ship passed by
I said to the Ghost Car Coast Guard like
hey there's somebody over here about
this how about it's hour 15. you you
have a headache you CA you lost 15
pounds so far yeah and you finally reach
your goal weight yeah that's one
positive you don't think anyone's coming
yeah and then you see a cruise ship
coming right at you oh my God how do you
get out of the way of the cruise ship
you can't you can't he could have got
run over by another cruise ship okay I'm
okay let's say you're in that scenario
are you going to try to swim
right left to get as far away or you're
going to go down in the water and trying
to get underneath no way I'm going down
so you're going right or left and trying
to get out of its wake yes go down how
deep can you go down plus the second you
go down you're holding your breath plus
you don't know how deep that [ __ ] cruise
ship goes down and you don't know what's
waiting for you down there who would go
down could be a bad neighborhood down
there it was sharp it could be a bad
neighborhood yeah
do you know what I did the other day you
know what I did how about this so I I
hosted a TV show right that just goes to
show you vaping is not good as per the
reports vaping is not good I did this
thing I don't think you were there for
this one pimp but I I hosted a TV show
right and it hasn't come out yet
um it's coming out we can't make an
announcement when I was pissed yeah when
you were passed away you got it um yeah
if anything I can't is this the V thing
right well the thing yeah we can't talk
about it where it is but just know that
it could come out if you have uh if you
have the rice Channel it might be on
that the what Bryce
um we can't say it oh rice right right
you know it's like you know yeah with a
V rice with a V and and so I don't know
if you want to say that yeah
so it's the Rive Channel The Ride
Channel yes so anyway so we the one the
last day of filming we had to film three
episodes in one day and I was the host
and in front of a live studio audience
and panelists and all that so you know
you start to get like so tired or
whatever and in the energy was really
low right yeah it was bad so I did you
have a warm-up comic yeah great warm-up
comment but there was no there was
nothing James matter was the one there
was nothing anybody could do this is
their third episode that they were
sitting there yeah for sick there's only
so much there's only so much James could
do they can't do it so I literally in
front of this is 200 people all the
executives from from from this channel
are there because New York yeah Stamford
Connecticut yeah so I literally like you
know they're like you know stop down
whatever like readjusting cameras
whatever and I just thought this would
be hilarious and it'll be like light in
the mood or whatever I ripped the
loudest part
oh [ __ ]
every single person
dead pin drop silence
even the panelists just looked at me and
then looked back at their phones
nobody
nobody said anything other than looking
at me as if to say what and then I hear
in my earpiece one of the dudes goes uh
Chris we're ready to start unless you
need the bathroom
[Laughter]
nobody laughed nobody said anything
nobody did it I mean and it was a wooden
sword I'm being ripped in front of a
cavernous studio with the mics and the
mics picked it up not even not I just
because
I ripped it like up like I went like
that on purpose ripped apart and then
smiled and started looking around I
jumped back there's something great and
people just looked at me and I I swear
to God I just turned and I adjusted the
mic on my shirt
[Laughter]
guys were ready to go and then I went
back and said welcome back to the show
I'm sweating uh it was so
true not one person said anything and it
was like friends of awesome James nobody
said anything I brought it up to Mike
Cannon who was the head writer who was
who was there in the room but didn't it
wasn't in the room for that moment I
said dude did you see like I ripped that
fart and like nobody said anything he
said yeah we were in the control and he
he said oh I said what happened in
Chrome did anybody laugh he said no they
were just like the Christian support
like and then they just went back to the
notes and then the people in the
audience were looking at me with this
disgust they were like and then I had to
do ready for this and then I had to do a
closing monologue for the last episode
that was like riddled with jokes and it
[ __ ] boxed because they were much
like your ass yeah we we hate this guy
and then in the show like absolutely I
said you guys aren't laughing at that
was it the fart and even that bombed no
it was dude oh I wonder if they were I
wanted to get I wonder if they were
rolling they must oh yeah I'm sure they
are maybe it'll be like a blooper thing
but I literally really it was one of
those moments where I before is a fun
word I ripped it and I thought it was
going to get such a big laugh and it
didn't and I immediately wanted to get
that moment in time back yeah because I
was like did you did you go into like a
mortified State yes yes because dude I
all of a sudden I got all your cards on
the table here's the thing I didn't even
realize how much I was sweating they had
to stop down about five minutes later
because makeup had to come and block my
forehead
reeling and embarrassing and then for
the next hour we filmed the show I could
think of nothing but of how much of an
answer I felt like from this far
so this has been hey babe
I don't know
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe